ja das ist der erste tag meiner kantine
oder selbstisolation ich habe jetzt
erfahren dass ich am 6 märz jemand
getroffen hatte der den ganzen tag mit
ihm zusammen war der inzwischen ja
positiv auf corona getestet worden ist
das heißt für mich ich kann es einfach
nicht mehr ausschließen dass sich
jemanden tagtäglich treffe der infiziert
ist und mich ansteckt und für mich wäre
das wirklich eine katastrophe ich habe
asthma war jetzt beim lungenarzt im
vorfeld eben von corona oder coop 19
bisher richtig heißt und der sagte halbe
lunge halbe lungenvolumen
entzündungswerte doppelt so hoch wäre
jetzt daraufhin auch behandelt aber
trotzdem ist das natürlich schwierig
also ich gehe jetzt in quarantäne und
zwar nach den regeln die das robert koch
institut empfohlen hat und das heißt
eigentlich gar nicht mehr raus gehen und
das habe ich vorbereitet weil ich soll
nach diesen regeln leben möglichst
keinen menschen mehr begegnen und das
gilt auch für den supermarkt wie soll
man dort den kontakt vermeiden
da stehen sich die menschen sehr nahe
schlangen es ist kaum möglich da die
anderthalb meter einzuhalten und immer
einen riesen respekt an alle
kassiererinnen und kassierer dort denn
die machen und wahnsinn job sie begegnen
an großteil der bevölkerung dort und
tragen damit ein erhebliches risiko
ich habe mich als jetzt hier vorbereitet
das heißt hier das ist ein fluren
gemeinsam auf tour mit den nachbarn
denen habe ich jetzt abgesperrt und das
ganze hier ist jetzt eine soll ist quasi
eine eine schleuse hinter dieser tür und
in dieser schleuse sind diese schleuse
ist quasi nicht ganz corona frei nach
definition spricht hier habe ich jetzt
fünf behälter aufgebaut die
gewährleisten sollen dass alles was am
ende hier ankommt corona frei ist denn
laut einer neuen studie ist es ja so
dass der virus etwa so 72 stunden
überlebt
an der an der luft ohne auf den menschen
zu sein und dann abstirbt sprich jeden
tag schreibe ich hier eine box weiter
hier kommt quasi das aktuelle rein und
dann am ende kann ich sicher sein es hat
so lange gelegen bei vier kein corona
kein virus mehr dran sein kann
das ganze ist nicht meine wohnung früher
habe ich hier gewohnt aber jetzt ist es
hier zum beispiel studio in dem united
creatures meine firma videos produziert
zum beispiel für den kanal klicks um
science-fiction und ja aber trotzdem
dadurch dass es früher eine wohnung war
und mein büro ist ist ja alles perfekt
das heißt ich kann zum einen hier
arbeiten alles ist da studio
schnittplätze und so weiter und so fort
und andererseits ist es aber auch eine
normale wohnung das heißt hier das ist
zum beispiel ein badezimmer mit dusche
noch kleiner und die wäsche im ganzen
welt rocken waschmaschine ist hier das
heißt hier kann ich auch was die muss
jetzt mal aus dem waschbecken ja spiegel
alles was man braucht für die
körperliche hygiene
ja und das ist unser besprechungsraum
arbeitstisch konferenztisch und eben
auch eine küche mit allem was man
braucht also ganz wichtig natürlich
kaffeemaschine erdplatten spülmaschine
waschmaschine
das heißt hier kann ich auch dafür
sorgen dass ich immer was zu essen habe
und das habe ich auch so vorbereitet
dass es mir nicht ausgehen wird hier
übrigens die werde ich jetzt mal hier
rausholen
das ist was wirklich fantastisch dass
ich bin nämlich kein anhänger von dosen
brot wie wahrscheinlich der eine oder
andere deutsche das ist eine
brutmaschine und auf der mit der werde
ich mir in den nächsten tagen dann
frisches brot backen zum einen super
frist zum anderen braucht man nur die
backmischung backmischung dafür besorgt
aufzubewahren und kann sich eine ganze
zeit mit frischem brot versorgen ja und
wie ich dann hier aktiv bin koche und
backe und mit was ich das mache was mir
dafür besorgt habe und wie ich natürlich
brot backe
das gibt es in den nächsten videos und
ich halte hier auf dem laufenden wie es
mir so geht und ja bin mal selber sehr
gespannt wohin das ganze führt ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran